He is the epitome of pure, unadulterated evil;
the mastermind guru with the swastika on his
forehead and the wild, crazed look in his
eyes.
He was responsible for the one of the most
heinous crimes of our time, controlling his
minions like a puppeteer.
In this week’s Biographics we discover the
dark, disturbing story of Charles Manson.
A Dysfunctional Beginning
Charles Milles Manson was born on November
12th, 1934 to sixteen-year old Kathleen Maddox
and a 24-year old transient laborer known
as ‘Colonel Scott’.
Kathleen was a promiscuous teenager who drank
too much and earned money to fuel her habits
be selling her body.
The baby was known as ‘No Name Maddox’
for the first few weeks of life until his
mother settled on Charlie.
He never knew his father; he cleared out as
soon he heard that Kathleen was pregnant.
Kathleen was too young, immature and unpredictable
to provide a stable environment for a young
child.
She appeared to have no maternal instinct
and would leave the child to fend for himself
while she went off on one of her benders.
As an adult, Charlie often related that his
mother was once in a café with him on her
knee when the waitress offered to buy the
baby from her.
Kathleen’s asking price was a pitcher of
beer and, having consumed it, she simply walked
out and left Charlie to the woman.
According to Charlie, his uncle took four
days to track him down and return him home.
When Charlie was six years old, his mother
and uncle decided to rob a gas station.
They were both caught, convicted and sent
for five years to Moundsville State Prison.
The boy was put into the care of his strictly
religious grandparents but after a few months
he went to live with his aunt and uncle in
McMecham, West Virginia.
This environment was very different to anything
Charlie had known previously.
His aunt, unlike her sister, was regimented
and disciplined.
She was also strictly religious.
Her husband, Bill, was even more fervent in
his faith than his wife.
A strict disciplinarian, he considered Charlie
to be a sissy.
On his first day of school he sent the boy
to class in a dress in order to teach him
how to fight.
Charlie soon adapted to this very different
kind of life and actually grew to enjoy his
new regimented routine.
The two years between six and eight were to
prove to be the most stable of his young life.
But then his mother was released from prison
and immediately took him back.
Kathleen was more unstable than ever.
She preferred a life of promiscuity and alcohol
abuse to maternal domesticity.
Constantly in trouble with the law and with
no money for food and board, the constantly
moved around the midWest.
At the age of nine, Charlie dropped out of
school.
The transient life that he was forced to live
shaped the type of boy that Charlie became.
He kept to himself, living his life through
his imagination.
He was constantly watching, taking things
in and dreaming of a future free of his no
hoper mother.
He also learnt how to become a very accomplished
thief.
At age nine, Charlie was caught stealing and
sent to reform school.
Three years later, he was caught again.
This time he was packed off to the Gibault
School for Boys in Terre Haute, Indiana.
Before he was taken away, Kathleen promised
to visit him often.
Of course, she never did.
Just ten months in to his incarceration, Charlie
escaped.
He robbed a grocery store to get some money
and, when that ran out, stole other things,
including a bicycle.
He got caught in the act of making off with
the bike and soon found himself back in confinement.
This time he was sent to an Indiana juvenile
center.
But after just two days, he stole some wire
cutters and freed, not only himself, but 30
other boys.
This time the escaped young felon stole, not
a bike, but a car.
But the 13-year old could hardly see over
the steering wheel and was apprehended within
hours of his escape.
When he ended up in juvenile court, he was
surprised to see his mother.
His spirits were dashed, however, when she
testified that she would not take him in.
The somewhat sympathetic judge sent Charlie
to Father Flanagan’s Boys Town.
But the stay here was almost as short as his
last incarceration.
After just four days, he ran off with another
young offender named Blackie Nelson.
They stole a car which they subsequently crashed.
Still, they made their way to the home of
Blackie’s uncle, a World War 2 veteran and
underworld figure who gave the young hoodlums
free board and food in exchange for the proceeds
from armed robberies that he made them commit.
During their third robbery the two boys were
caught.
This time Charlie was sent to the Indiana
School for Boys in Plainfield.
Here he stayed for three years.
Charlie would later claim that his small stature
led to him being constantly raped and sodomized
by other inmates as well as by school employees.
He also recalled that he was constantly picked
on by the guards, who would continually find
fault with him, beating him with leather straps
and wooden clubs.
An Angry Young Man
One night, after being gang raped by a group
of older boys, he beat one of his attackers
to just short of the point of death with an
iron bar as the boy lay sleeping.
Charlie then placed the bar under the bed
of one of his other attackers, successfully
implicating him in the attack.
Charlie was exhibiting a trait that would
characterize his personality as an adult;
he would hold in his anger for a time, only
for it too explode in an orgy of violence.
Over the three years that he spent at Plainfield,
Charlie escaped no less than eighteen times.
He was returned every time.
In March, 1951 his sentence was increased
and he was sent to a minimum-security institution.
He was sent to the National Training School
for Boys in Washington, D.C.
Things here were very different to what Charlie
had known at Plainfield.
The facility was well run, the boys were treated
well and a genuine focus was placed on rehabilitation.
Charlie liked it here but he had no interest
in being rehabilitated.
He’d do his time but then he’d get back
to the life of crime that he was the only
life he knew.
At around the age of fifteen, Charlie was
give a psychiatric assessment.
He was found to be aggressive, antisocial
and illiterate.
A caseworker reported that the boy was severely
emotionally traumatized and in serious need
of psychiatric treatment.
It was also noted that he had a higher than
normal aptitude for music.
On October 24th, 1951, Charlie was transferred
to the Natural Bridge Honor Camp in Petersburg,
Virginia.
Three months later, just weeks before his
parole hearing, he sodomized another inmate
while holding a razor blade to his neck.
He was reclassified as extremely dangerous
and transferred to a tougher high security
facility – the Federal Reformatory at Petersburg,
Virginia.
After seven months at the Federal Reformatory,
Charlie had racked up eight major violations.
He was classified as ‘defiantly homosexual,
dangerous and safe only under supervision,
with assaultive tendencies.’
Towards the end of 1952, he was sent to a
higher security facility.
There, to the surprise of everybody, he transformed
into a model prisoner.
He took lessons in reading and math and began
working in the vehicle maintenance department.
On January 1st, 1954, he was given a Meritorious
Service Award for his scholastic achievements.
His application to his studies and his apparent
change of attitude led to Charlie being paroled
on May 8th, 1954.
He was put in the care of his aunt and uncle
but, within a month, the now nineteen-year-old
was back living with his mother, herself recently
released from prison.
Career Felon
Six months after his release, Charlie married
a waitress by the name of Rosalie Jean Willis.
Shortly thereafter a son, Charles Manson,
Junior, was born.
Charlie worked at a serious low-income job,
augmenting his pay by stealing cars.
He used one of those stolen cars to move his
wife and baby to Los Angeles.
The car had been taken from Ohio and authorities
were able to track it down.
Charlie was charged with a federal crime for
taking the car across state lines.
He received five years’ probation but, when
he failed to show up to a subsequent hearing,
he was arrested.
With his probation revoked, Charlie was sent
for three years to the prison on Terminal
Island, in San Pedro, California.
After being there a few months, he was informed
that his wife was living with another man.
Two years later, she obtained a decree of
divorce.
In September, 1958, Charlie was released on
five years parole.
He now extended his criminal earning potential
by becoming a pimp.
He had a sixteen-year-old girl working for
him.
Over the next year, he roamed around California
and New Mexico, committing crimes and repeatedly
coming before the law.
In June, 1960 he fled to Laredo, Texas with
a California warrant out for his arrest.
When one of his girls was arrested there for
prostitution, he was picked up and returned
to Los Angeles to face a 10-year sentence
for cashing a forged treasury check.
At the age of 26, he was sent to the U.S.
Penitentiary at McNeil Island, Washington.
While serving his sentence he learned to play
the guitar and became interested in Scientology.
During his time at McNeil Island, he also
became obsessed with the Beatles.
Charlie had an inflated appreciation of his
own musical talent, claiming that he would,
with the right backing and training, be even
bigger than the Beatles.
Charlie became friends with an inmate by the
name of Alvin Karpis.
This former Public Enemy Number One was a
former member of the infamous Ma Barker gang.
He taught Charlie how to play the steel guitar.
This further fuelled his musical obsession.
In 1966, Charlie’s prison record noted that
he spent most of his free time writing songs,
accumulating 80 or 90 of them in a year.
Karpis later commented on the Charlie that
he knew at that time.
He recalled that Manson was a master manipulator
of other people.
Prison authorities also noted that he had
a tremendous drive to call attention to himself.
In June, 1966, Charlie was sent once again
to Terminal Island – this time in preparation
for early release.
When that release day arrived on March 21st,
1967, he had spent more than half of his 32
years behind bars.
He requested that the authorities let him
stay in jail but he was told that he had to
leave.
Charlie Unleashed
And so it was that the five foot nothing drifter
with the penetrating stare and gift of the
gab wandered into the Haight-Ashbury district
of San Francisco with $35 in his pocket and
no plans except for a desire to make it big
in the music business.
Charlie moved into an apartment in Berkeley
and made money by panhandling.
Before long he had gotten to know a 23-year-old
assistant librarian at UC Berkeley named Mary
Brunner.
He quickly won her over and moved into her
apartment.
Brunner came under Charlie’s spell and he
convinced her to widen out the home.
Within a few months, there were eighteen young
women living with them.
Charlie introduced Mary and the other girls
to drugs and before long Mary had quit her
job and become a devoted follower of Manson.
The ‘family’ was beginning to take shape.
With his female entourage and his guitar,
Charlie merged perfectly into the hippie culture
that was then in full bloom in San Francisco.
He refined his role as spiritual master, guru
and prophet, using mind control techniques
to get his girls to do whatever he wanted.
Most of the girls that he gathered around
him came from troubled backgrounds and suffered
from insecurities that left them directly
about open to Charlie’s manipulations.
As well as breaking down their inhibitions
with mind control techniques, he used LSD
and amphetamines to control his ever-expanding
harem.
After about nine months living in and around
San Francisco, Charlie began to despair of
the place.
It had, he asserted become too overrun with
African Americans and crime was rampant.
Of course, the ‘Family’ were doing their
bit to add to those crime statistics.
They stole credit cards and used counterfeit
money to get what they needed.
They also stole a big yellow bus and painted
it black.
The Family
Charlie and his followers took to travelling
by bus down the California coastline as far
as Mexico and Texas, partying and committing
more crimes.
After eighteen months of extended travel,
they finally settled in Topanga Canyon near
Los Angeles in a two-storey house.
It was here that Charlie began gathering some
male members to the Family.
The first was a teenager named Bobby Beausoliel,
who turned up one night for a party and then
stayed on as Charlie’s right-hand man.
Bobby had been staying with his music teacher
Gary Hinman not far from the Manson home.
Bobby recruited an 18-year-old named Leslie
Van Houtein to the family in June, 1968.
Around that time, Charlie and some of the
girls travelled to Los Angeles where he met
up with a record executive at universal studios.
Former jail friend Phil Kaufman had arranged
the meeting.
This was Charlie’s entry into the rich jet
set crowd and he turned on all his charm to
make a good impression.
Soon the ‘Family’ were rubbing shoulders
with the rich and famous at posh parties in
the Hollywood Hills.
In the late spring of 1968, Beach Boys drummer
Dennis Wilson was driving away from Malibu
Beach when he happened to pick up two hitchhikers.
The girls were part of the Manson family and,
they quickly agreed to go back to his Beverly
Hills home with Wilson on Sunset Boulevard.
The three made love that afternoon and then
Wilson left for a recording session, promising
to return later to take up where they left
off.
When Wilson returned home in the early hours
of the following morning, he was surprised
to see that a full-scale party was underway.
He was greeted in the driveway by a short
man with a scraggly beard who approached him,
dropped to his knees and began kissing his
feet.
The girls who Dennis had met earlier came
running out declaring, ‘This is the guy
we were telling you about . . . this is Charlie.’
Inside his home, Wilson found twelve more
women, most of them topless, lying around
smoking pot.
Manson told him that the girls were all there
for Wilson’s pleasure.
Wilson was impressed with the sway that Charlie
held over the women.
He welcomed the ‘Family’ with open arms
and his home become the regular venue for
Charlie orchestrated orgies.
Wilson called Manson the Wizard and began
inviting influential showbiz friends to come
and meet him.
Dennis also allowed Charlie to use anything
he wanted – his Ferrari or Rolls Royce and
all the food drink and drugs he or his groupies
wanted.
Eventually Wilson’s manager became fed up
with the influence and expense that Manson
was having on his client and Charlie and the
girls were ordered out of the mansion.
Rumors were also spreading of the children
of the rich and famous being given drugs and
having sex under Charlies direction.
Suddenly, the door to the Hollywood elite
lifestyle was slammed shut.
Charlie’s planned for music career was also
shut down.
This caused that familiar build up of jealousy,
anger and rage that would inevitably find
expression in violence.
Manson managed to convince the owner of a
former Western movie set, the Spahn Ranch,
in Chatswood, not far from Topanga Canyon,
to allow the family to live on the abandoned
property.
The family now moved to the ranch, getting
by stealing and scavenging.
Charlie took to quoting the Bible to Family
members as they gathered round a bonfire during
the evenings.
He also interpreted Beatles songs, explaining
that the lyrics were directed toward them.
He was obsessed with one song ‘Helter Skelter’,
telling his followers that the song envisioned
an apocalypse brought on by a race war of
blacks killing whites.
The blacks would win, he said, but would then
turn to Manson to lead the new world.
Helter Skelter
For Charlie, however, the revolution was taking
too long.
He wanted it to happen immediately.
He began preparing family members for a series
of actions that would precipitate the black
uprising.
The first step would be to release an album
of music that would contain subtle messages
that would foment the black revolution.
On May 18th, 1969, Terry Melcher, a producer
who Charlie had met through Dennis Wilson
arrived at Spahn Ranch to listen to Charlie
and the girls sing.
Melcher made promises but never followed through
on them.
On July 25th 1969, Charlie ordered Bobby Beausoliel
and two women to the home of Gary Hindman,
the music teacher who Bobby used to live with.
Manson had heard that Hindman had inherited
$20,000 and he wanted it.
Hinman refused to hand over the money.
Charlie was called and he soon arrived.
After screaming at Hinman, Charlie pulled
out a sword and cut off his ear.
He then left, giving instructions to get the
money or kill Hinman.
After three days, Bobby stabbed his former
teacher to death.
Before leaving he and the girls wrote the
words ‘Political Piggy’ on the wall along
with a panther paw in red to lay the blame
on the Black Panther movement.
Bobby Beusoliel was arrested for the murder
on August 6th, 1969 after being caught driving
around in Hinman’s car.
Manson was now ready to get his revenge on
Terry Melcher, the record producer who had
let him down.
On the evening of August 8th, he directed
followers Tex Watson, Linda Kasabian, Susan
Atkins and Patricia Krenwinkel to the house
where he believed Melcher was living with
instructions to ‘totally destroy everyone
in it, making it as gruesome as possible.’
The house was located at 1050 Celio Drive
but Melcher didn’t live there anymore.
It was now occupied by famous director Roman
Polanski and his beautiful 8-month pregnant
wife, actress Sharon Tate.
That night, Polanski was in Europe on a film
project.
His wife was entertaining guests at the property
– hairdresser Jay Sebring, screenwriter
Voyteg Frykowski and coffee empire heiress
Abigail Folger.
Arriving at the property, around midnight,
Watson climbed a telephone pole near the gate
and cut the phone line.
The car was then back to the bottom of a hill
that led to the house and the murder team
walked up to find the victims.
Watson thought the gate might be electrified
so he and the girls climbed a brushy embankment
to get onto the grounds.
Just then, car headlights came on from farther
up the property.
Ordering the women to lie down in the bushes,
Watson approached the vehicle and levelled
his 22-caliber rifle at the driver, 18-year-ol
Steven Parent.
Watson first slashed hm with a knife and them
shot him four times in the chest.
Watson then ordered Linda Kasabian to keep
watch down by the gate.
He and the other two women then made their
way to the house.
The occupants were quickly gathered together
in the lounge.
When asked by Frykowski who they were, Watson
replied, “I’m the devil and I’m here
to do the devil’s work.’
Watson then began to tie the heavily pregnant
Sharon Tate and Jay Sebring together by their
necks with rope he’d brought and slung over
a beam.
When Sebring protested over the rough handling
of Sharon, Watson shot him and then stabbed
him seven times.
Meanwhile Frykowski began struggling with
Susan Atkins, who repeatedly stabbed him in
the legs and torso.
Still Frykowski managed to get to the front
door.
Seeing this, Watson rushed after him, meeting
up with him on the porch and smashing in his
head with the gun butt before shooting him
twice.
Abigail Folger had managed to escape out onto
the yard.
She was chased by Patricia Krenwikel who tackled
her and then stabbed her to death.
The only remaining victim was now Sharon Tate.
As she lay on the lounge room floor with a
rope around her neck she begged to be able
to live long enough to have her child.
But her pleas were ignored and either Watson
or Atkins stabbed her repeatedly, including
in the abdomen, until both she and her unborn
baby were dead.
Remembering Manson’s instructions to leave
a sign on the walls, Atkins wrote the word
“PIG” with Tate’s blood.
The very next day, the Family struck again.
This time the victims were Leno and Rosemary
LaBianca.
Unhappy with the messiness of the previous
night’s killings, this time Charlie went
with the group to show them how it was done.
Different accounts have been giving about
the exact happenings that night but we do
know that Manson was in the house and he orchestrated
the tying up of the couple, He then left with
orders that the couple be killed.
They were finished off by Watson with a chrome
plated bayonet.
Before leaving the words “WAR”, “Rise”,
“Death To Pigs” and “Healter Skelter’
were written with the blood of the victims
on the walls and refrigerator door.
Caught
The murders caused a huge panic through Hollywood.
The pressure was now on to solve the heinous
crimes.
The police got nowhere until they finally
linked the Hinman murder to the Tate-LaBianca
killings.
They knew that Bobby Beusoliel had lived with
a group of hippies at Spahn Ranch so they
decided to pay the ranch a visit.
Bobby’s girlfriend had told police that
Charlie Manson, the hippie guru, had ordered
the killing of Hinman.
Still there was no evidence linking the group
to the later murders.
Then, in October, twenty-four Manson family
members, including Charlie, were arrested
on charges of arson and grand theft.
Susan Atkins was also taken into custody and
it was she who first began to spill beans.
She bragged to a cellmate about killing Sharon
Tate, giving a detailed account and implicating
Charlie as the mastermind.
About the same time, police interviewed a
member of the Straight Satans motorcycle gang
who was a Manson acquaintance.
He told them that Manson had recently been
bragging about ‘knocking off’ five people.
The first piece of physical evidence was a
fingerprint of Patricia Rewinkle that was
found on Sharon Tate’s bedroom door.
When other pieces of physical evidence were
recovered, the police were ready to send the
case to court.
Manson and the four people who had committed
the Tate-La Bianca murders were found guilty
and sentenced to death.
These penalties, however, would never be imposed.
In 1972 the California Supreme Court declared
the state’s death penalty law unconstitutional.
Manson’s’ death sentence was commuted
to life imprisonment.
Charles Manson died on November 19, 2017,
of cardiac arrest having spent nearly fifty
years behind bars for his orchestrating of
the crimes that shook the world in 1969.
He was 83 years of age.